why are there dead birds in my future oh
that's definitely your present this is
Gary
he's a tarot card reader an energy
healer from Brooklyn Gary tells me that
he's one of only a handful of black
tarot card readers in the country many
of whom grew up watching Miss Cleo on TV
and despite the controversy surrounding
her she inspired a new generation of
black tarot card readers so today my
friends and I sat down with Gary to have
our cards read for the very first time
hi I'm Lea and we are doing tarot card
readings for the first time hi my name
is aja and I'm getting a tarot card
reading done for the first time what's
up I'm Theresa I'm doing a tarot card
reading for the first time with Gary
welcome so as this is your first tarot
card reading I like to give everybody
the skinny off top basically what this
is is the energy that is surround
hearing it's very moment in time we're
going to look at it and past present
future looking at what's happening maybe
around you in the present what may have
been going on in the past how that can
enforce in a vector future right now
what I need for you to do for me please
just state your full name three times
that's your full government aim if you
don't feel like it you can just say your
first name first name last name or
nickname to be submissive to you so
that's scary that's like that which is
named like three times god we don't have
to worry about it it's just so that way
I'm able to tap into your energy and
give things for that okay okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
alright having any father or mother you
love me I can do okay
president alright anything else we got
more let's see what's coming up all
right is that it that's it okay now in
the past you used to be a little money
hungry the fashion the cars like the
gold like that was your whole steel
house for ya and you have to remember
that you let that go you let that go you
transition to a place where you're
looking at things that how does it make
you feel instead of what does it look
like on the outside
okay the dwarves and gnomes are coming
up because they are representative and
elements but they're representative in
everything that's around us like the
ground the universe what have you how
you keep yourself grounded and you
didn't know how to keep yourself
grounded before it was in the wrong
stuff okay
past experience is truly traumatic but
could have been a learning experience or
a warning a learning experience
definitely so allow it to purport you
forward instead of taking you back okay
and allow it to be something that you
gain from instead of thinking that we
lose yeah I think in the past I've had a
lot of trust issues and and I keep
saying that and as I'm like allowing
more people into my life or wanting more
people into my life mm-hmm it's it's
hard for me to be volvo it it's just
hard I'm so proud of you for saying
doing and not trying I'm trying to do it
out that's one of the things that I
don't allow like we ain't trying we
doing out here so you are doing that and
doing the work and that's all this being
asked of you the guardian angel car is
representative of that divine feminine
energy like India Maya that is
surrounding you at this very moment I'm
is always around to you what's the water
boring me what does that mean so that
means that obviously you'd like to pour
into others correct you like to share
time like pouring into others and you
see that as we are surrounded by all of
these you've got the earth represented
in the different clay pots you have
obviously the ground there you've got
the sky so this is literally the balance
of thoughts the balance of creation so
reminding yourself that in order for you
to stay balanced you have to bring that
into your life and number your point to
others
keeping yourself grounded what does that
look like every day I feel like this
means like I was literally porn glasses
of wine for people last night maybe
that's what it is
let's keep their going and keep it
rockin Oh
what does this mean that's definitely
your present so the six of fire is
representative of the people winning the
battle they're bringing home the woman
they have succeeded things are going
pretty awesome so congratulations you I
don't know if are you did you two get
into a relationship of some sort or but
what's this reaction because this
reactions giving me so much right now
you're just like oh crap that's cool you
just said bring home the one so don't
make my mom happy but I don't I don't
think of anything in particular so let's
go ahead and see what comes up both
Charlotte comes up you have the ace of
fire and you also have get my yah do you
have any Aries or any Leo's in your life
right now my best friend is a Leo mm-hmm
Aries I feel like I don't get along with
arias maybe that's why it's something
about them that you can potentially
learn something okay or something that
you could potentially learn from your
best friend is this best friend kind of
like charge you up hype you up and stuff
like that so that's what you need to be
making sure that you're taking in
because it's coming to you and you're
just like I'm not sure like you can
question yourself that we don't do that
around me okay so you have to make sure
that you are being that divine feminine
energy that's with you my god is
representative she's the Divine Mother
she's huge like into really sharing that
love really sharing that compassion that
maternal energy you have
about yourself so if you are not paying
attention to that right now you need to
lean into them also when's the last time
you called your mother often have you
not been calling your mother recently
has it been falling off a little bit
you know what's crazy my mom said
yesterday it's been two days call your
mom how much time do you spend like
conversing with your family how close
are you to your family I'm not super
close I don't spend that much time
talking to them and do you have like a
lot of friends that are more like
families yes okay so this is what I want
you to like focus on right now whatever
you consider family because when I asked
that family you went automatically to
your like blood relatives family is
family no matter what it is so I want
you to focus on how do you create family
and what does that make you feel like
okay in their present y'all so let's go
ahead and happen to your future so this
looks very very grim who's dead burn
those are dead birds I want you to pay
attention to the fact that is upside
down so the fact of the matter is the 10
of air when it's right side up means
that you've been hunted things have been
happening in your life where you're
trying to just like people are really
pushing for your energy pushing for your
attention but you've gotten to a place
where you've overcome that and now you
are able to live in freedom again
instead of feeling all that stress from
all those people just against what go
ahead
so these dead birds represent people not
necessarily people people's energies so
bad energies are dead now let's see
what's coming up for your future ok they
said let's go ahead and get this
information out before we go to the end
this one no this one okay you're free oh
it's the enslave business so of course
when you think of a prisoner you think
of somebody that is talk badly about
somebody that is held back from kind of
like tapping to their true potential
right this is showing up in Reverse
which means you've broken free of the
chains okay you know what it takes to
allow yourself to be 100
and authentic in who you are so lean
into that understanding for whatever it
is so this is really telling you you
have that fire insider you knew that in
the past that's what gets you to a
future of not having to worry about
anything the only reason why you can
allow yourself to shrink and back up is
when you trust through people
trust your people you'll allow yourself
to never see the village on fire so just
lean into the understanding of hey this
was the past the senior cycle I'm a new
woman and I can make this work and I
have people that I trust that I know
will build me up always oh that's
definitely your present